hey what up it's your boy too depressed
to work so I filled this bag with Taco
Bell
let's go spoil end game alright so the
first step for spoiling end game is you
want to have at least a reasonable
understanding of what happens in the
movie and the most efficient way of
accomplishing that is to just go see it
so I guess that's the next step so this
is possibly the weirdest thing to gripe
about but they made they change the
ticket printer and they're just they're
so long now like look how long these
tickets are it's as long as my hand
alright next step try to make sure you
get a somewhat reasonable seat
[Music]
all right now that you've seen infinity
war you're ready to spoil it
but you're already at the mall so you
might as well go like get a hoodie or
something okay so first off I just want
to warn you that endgame is full of a
ton of spoilers for Avengers endgame so
if you don't want to be spoiled on
endgame don't go see Avengers endgame
it's like just wall to wall spoilers you
know I'm just gonna say it doesn't
matter how depressed you are if your
brain tells you to get 10 burritos don't
do it so if you just want to be able to
talk about endgame but you don't want to
have to be like if you don't want to
have to deal with the burden of details
then your main talking points are going
to be about how introspective the first
hour is how fans services the last hour
is and the the great use of wide shots
that there's some very well-composed
wide shots and and and beats in in the
movie and so like if you just kind of
take those three vague talking points
and just ramble about how like oh man
you know I really did like how
introspective the first hour is like it
was really really had the characters
like look inside themselves and and
grapple with sort of the meaning of
things you know if you just riff like
that for a good five minutes you can
convince anyone that you actually saw
the movie I want to keep going but it's
way too hot in my car and I'm right next
to a highway so if I open my window
there's gonna be way too much noise so
let's let's go home and do this
now if you don't want to be burdened
with details but you want to sound like
you can talk about the movie but you
don't want to sound like super positive
then your core talking points are going
to be that like the middle of the movie
is just like kind of there it's just a
lot of make work and a lot of it doesn't
really have you know stakes or
complications that that come back in any
meaningful way that Captain Marvel is
integrated into the film in a really in
elegant way and that that for a huge
chunk of the movie they basically push
every female character off screen but
then they all get a giant like action
group shot together and I guess that's
supposed to make it all okay that it's
like well hey look they get a big moment
of badass it's like it's like a yearbook
photo of kick-ass female characters
sorry only one and a half of them got
actual emotional development during the
film itself so if you're looking for the
kind of raw spoilers that you're going
to like shout out the window of a car
the main ones would be the fan oohs gets
pumped in like the first 10 minutes of
the movie Black Widow dies
Iron Man dies and Captain America gets
old and retires so so those are gonna be
your four main like things that people
are gonna be like the most sensitive
about because they're you know twists or
major plot developments or whatnot hey
Amy what are you getting into over there
hey Amy what are you getting into Amy
Amy
sitting through the movie and going
through it it was it was very well
constructed and it was an enjoyable ride
and I had a good time and it was
emotionally satisfying but kind of in
substantial like it's been an hour and a
bit since I got out of the movie and and
already I feel like I've moved on like
I'm I'm I'm done in a certain way
there's actually kind of this catharsis
because it's like the the core the the
MCU that has been just bloating and and
and building for the last decade 20
some-odd
movies it's like okay it's over we are
free so how the plot ends up playing out
is that basically the Avengers can't
just fix the problem and completely undo
the first movie so what they have to do
is they they do a time heist they go
they build a time machine go back in
time steal the Infinity stones from
various points in the previous movies
with the promise that they're gonna come
back and like return them kind of like
we'll be back in a minute like one
minute after we take the stones we'll
just show up and put them back and it'll
all be good and you know and and through
this past Thanos ends up getting alerted
to their plan and so the big showdown at
the end of the movie after everyone has
been unsnapped is a showdown between all
the heroes and a past version of Thanos
so you have everybody getting revenge
on the same dude a dude who has not yet
done the thing that you're getting
revenge on him for even though he like
personality-wise has 100% confirmed that
he would do the same thing again and is
in fact actively trying to accomplish
exactly the thing like he still needs to
be stopped he is still trying to get the
gauntlet and like snap everyone and also
as far as he's concerned well I guess
because it's now in a he's trying to
like redo it but anyway like I feel like
a bunch of the meat is taken out of it
by the fact that like this Thanos
doesn't know any of these people and
hasn't seen them before and there's even
a moment that calls attention to this
we're like so Scarlet Witch after she
gets on snap she gets a little
one-on-one duel with Thanos and and
she's like you took everything from me
because vision doesn't come back cuz
vision got killed not snapped so vision
is still dead so she's like you took
everything from me and and he's just
like I don't know who you are
she's like you will and I thought that
was gonna be a setup for her like for
like a moment where she uses her powers
to like show him the consequences of
what he did but no they just they just
punch each other
I'm just gonna sit here and eat the
remainder of all of these